Jake:呀你昨天全给你了
Jake: Yeah, I gave you everything yesterday.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 因为你说这样就不用发我的工资了
Tasha: Because you said that way you wouldn't have to pay my salary.
Jake:哦确实
Jake: Oh, true.
Tasha: 你不就是这个意思吗
Tasha: Isn't that what you meant?
Jake:是这个意思人挺好
Jake: That's what I meant, you're pretty nice.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Jake:开了吗
Jake: Did it bloom?
Katrina: 开了
Katrina: It did.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:咱今整点啥
Jake: What are we doing today?
Tasha: 做啥都可以
Tasha: We can do anything.
Jake:要做多少要做多少
Jake: How much should we make?
Tasha: 做多少都可以
Tasha: We can make as much as we want.
Jake:东西
Jake: Stuff...
Tasha: 做多少都可以
Tasha: We can make as much as we want.
Jake:做多少都可以
Jake: We can make as much as we want.
Tasha: 现在开始做也可以
Tasha: We can start now.
Tasha: 对做做
Tasha: Yeah, let's do it.
Tasha: 你想吃什么
Tasha: What do you want to eat?
Jake:嗯还有啥没做的吗
Jake: Hmm, is there anything we haven't made yet?
Katrina: 提拉米苏
Katrina: Tiramisu.
Jake:芋头啊好嘞
Jake: Taro, alright.
Tasha: 芋头到不了了
Tasha: The taro won't make it.
Jake:为啥呀
Jake: Why?
Shure: 请塔莎老师
Shure: Please, Teacher Tasha.
Jake:傻傻的咖啡
Jake: Silly coffee.
Tasha: 怎么是热的
Tasha: Why is it hot?
Jake:放点冰块
Jake: Add some ice cubes.
Jake:呵咱冰块是说要买是吧
Jake: Haha, we need to buy ice cubes, right?
Katrina: 美团
Katrina: Meituan.
Shure: 冰块有
Shure: We have ice cubes.
Jake:冰块有有了
Jake: We have ice cubes, got it.
Jake:是吗哪了好买了是吧
Jake: Really? Where? Oh, we bought them, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 哪呢
Tasha: Where?
Shure: 在楼下的那个
Shure: In the downstairs one.
Tasha: 哦冰格里是吗
Tasha: Oh, in the ice tray?
Shure: 不是就是上次想起来没对
Shure: No, just remembered last time, no.
Katrina: 你美团还送
Katrina: Your Meituan still delivers.
Katrina: 送的那一坨
Katrina: Delivered that chunk.
Shure: 凑单然后我凑了一袋瓶
Shure: Added up, then I got a bag of bottles.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 你要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Shure: 你用吗我不用
Shure: Do you need it? I don't.
Shure: 你先用吧
Shure: You use it first.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:好加冰
Jake: Okay, add ice.
Shure: 洗葡萄
Shure: Washing grapes.
Tasha: 算了不能加
Tasha: Never mind, can't add it.
Shure: 你洗你葡萄
Shure: You wash your grapes.
Shure: 我冲我的咖啡
Shure: I'll make my coffee.
Tasha: 不能喝冰
Tasha: Can't drink iced drinks.
Jake:你不要
Jake: You don't want it.
Shure: 这可以丢掉
Shure: This can be thrown away.
Shure: 其实你先给他放那放那吧
Shure: Actually, just put it there for now.
Shure: 先一会丢了
Shure: Throw it away later.
Shure: 记得我们有这个有这个
Shure: Remember we have this, have this.
Shure: 要丢的东西
Shure: Things to throw away.
Katrina: 这有碟子吗这边
Katrina: Are there any plates here?
Shure: 有吧
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Shure: 怎么不满了
Shure: Why isn't it full?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 站你旁边碍你眼了是吗
Shure: Standing next to you and bothering you, huh?
Katrina: 哈我要摔碟子骂人了
Katrina: Haha, I'm going to throw plates and yell at people.
Katrina: 太阳好好啊
Katrina: The sun is so nice.
Katrina: 又要洗衣服
Katrina: Time to do laundry.
Shure: 要骂厨子了是吗
Shure: Going to yell at the cook, huh?
Katrina: 还有养乐多吗
Katrina: Do we still have Yakult?
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 之前看人家说亲戚家养乐多
Katrina: I saw someone say their relatives have Yakult.
Katrina: 捣捣捣捣
Katrina: Smash, smash, smash.
Katrina: 把它捣碎那种很爽
Katrina: Crushing it feels so good.
Katrina: 你洗吧
Katrina: You wash it.
Katrina: 那这个要留着明天
Katrina: Let's save this for tomorrow.
Katrina: 哈哈等会再买
Katrina: Haha, let's buy more later.
Katrina: 反正今天要交外送是吧
Katrina: We're doing delivery today, right?
Shure: 对可以直接点盒马外送的其实
Shure: Yeah, we can just order from Hema directly.
Katrina: 明天还需要再买
Katrina: We need to buy more tomorrow.
Katrina: 这是在干什么
Katrina: What is this about?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: 磨豆子
Katrina: 哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh.
Katrina: 这个是民宿自带的吗
Katrina: Is this provided by the B&B?
Katrina: 还是你带过来的
Katrina: Or did you bring it?
Shure: 什么哪个
Shure: What, which one?
Shure: 这个这这套
Shure: This, this set?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 这套是自带的
Shure: This set is provided.
Katrina: 哎现在可以把压花放外面哦
Katrina: Hey, now we can put the press flowers outside.
Katrina: 已经在外面没收
Jake:二次花多少钱啊
Jake: How much does the second batch cost?
Katrina: 放晒会太阳估计就很快感
Katrina: If you let it dry in the sun, it should be quick.
Katrina: 你昨天晚上不是说要通宵写完吗
Katrina: Didn't you say you were going to stay up all night to finish it?
Katrina: 倒头睡了
Katrina: I just fell asleep.
Katrina: 不是吧不是吧
Katrina: No way, no way.
Shure: 但我今天早上起来也搞了一些
Shure: But I did some things this morning.
Shure: 因为我一直还有个东西没跑
Shure: Because there's still something I haven't done.
Shure: 然后今天早上买了个服务器
Shure: And I bought a server this morning.
Shure: 然后去跑了一下
Shure: And then I ran a test.
Shure: 腾讯云的那个
Shure: It's from Tencent Cloud.
Shure: 真那下载速度忒慢了
Shure: But the download speed is so slow.
Shure: 他那服务器给的下载速度
Shure: The server's download speed.
Shure: 那个带宽就5兆
Shure: 然后下东西就他妈500K我靠
Shure: And the download speed is just 500Kbps, damn.
Katrina: 要他们开会是不是
Katrina: 或者是要买
Katrina: Or needs to be bought.
Shure: 不是不是不是开会员
Shure: No, no, not opening a membership.
Katrina: 要买
Katrina: We need to buy it.
Katrina: 还是说他本来就这么忙啊
Katrina: Or is he just always this busy?
Shure: 他他他
Shure: He he he...
Shure: 就就只有那么那么那么大的下行
Shure: There's only so much bandwidth.
Shure: 下行速度
Shure: Download speed.
Katrina: 那他不怕倒闭吗
Katrina: Isn't he afraid of going out of business?
Shure: 很奇怪
Shure: Very strange.
Shure: 但那卡还可以
Shure: But the card is still okay.
Katrina: 耶耶
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 斜着点我干啥
Katrina: Why am I doing this diagonally?
Katrina: 我要把干花压花拿到那块
Katrina: I need to move the dried flowers over there.
Lucia: 会不会过于真实了
Lucia: Is it too real?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:我们压花怎么说
Jake: What about the pressed flowers?
Jake:我们压花现在是什么
Jake: What's the status with the pressed flowers?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia: 昨天的压花可以取了吗
Lucia: Can we take the pressed flowers from yesterday now?
Katrina: 里面有蜜蜂唉
Katrina: There's a bee inside!
Lucia: 哎没有我刚打开的
Lucia: No, there isn't. I just opened it.
Katrina: 还没有我刚打开的
Katrina: Not yet, I just opened it.
Katrina: 嗯我们去帮他晒一会太阳应该
Katrina: Hmm, we should let them dry in the sun for a while.
Lucia: 可以好的
Lucia: Okay, sure.
Katrina: 但是昨天下午才压应该还不够
Katrina: But they were just pressed yesterday afternoon, so it's probably not enough time yet.
Lucia: 我刚才就是把它打开
Lucia: I just opened it earlier.
Lucia: 之后在想能不能就是整个拆开
Lucia: I was wondering if we could take it all apart.
Lucia: 但我又不敢
Lucia: But I didn't dare.
Lucia: 所以我又没拆
Lucia: So I didn't.
Jake:然后这些花是放回卧室是吗还是搁这
Jake: So, are we putting these flowers back in the bedroom or leaving them here?
Katrina: 可以放回卧室
Katrina: We can put them back in the bedroom.
Jake:那就放回卧室吧
Jake: Then let's put it back in the bedroom.
Katrina: 今天等一会
Katrina: Just wait for a while today.
Katrina: 下午看一下有没有压好的
Katrina: Check in the afternoon to see if any are pressed properly.
Katrina: 有的那个花瓣可能就好了
Katrina: If they are, the petals might be ready.
Katrina: 就可以自己做点明信片
Katrina: Then we can make some postcards ourselves.
Jake:那我们先把这个花给放回去
Jake: Let's put these flowers back first.
Jake:让客厅看起来东西少一点
Jake: Make the living room look a bit less cluttered.
Katrina: 好不容易啊
Katrina: It's not easy, huh?
Katrina: leader居然开始发布命令
Katrina: 我这还有个手工
Katrina: I still have some crafts here.
Katrina: 给它放在阳光底下怎么样
Katrina: How about putting it under the sunlight?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 追求卓越书写未来
Lucia: Pursue excellence and write the future.
Katrina: 我靠追求卓越是我们校训
Katrina: Oh wow, "Pursue excellence" is our school motto.
Lucia: 啊哈哈是你高中的校训吗
Lucia: Haha, was that your high school motto?
Katrina: 吓我一跳
Katrina: It scared me.
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina: 我们大学校训就是什么追求卓越
Katrina: It was the motto of my university, "Pursue excellence."
Katrina: 我要做我的手工
Katrina: I want to work on my crafts.
Lucia: 哦这是谢斌竹的烟
Lucia: Oh, this is Sherin's cigarette.
Lucia: 是吧我可要偷偷抽一根
Lucia: Right? I'll secretly smoke one.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 你会吗
Lucia: 不是很会
Lucia: Not really.
Lucia: 能抽起来但是不是很会
Lucia: I can smoke, but I'm not very good at it.
Katrina: 哇你怎么会抽的呀
Katrina: Wow, how did you learn to smoke?
Lucia: 哈哈我朋友会抽
Lucia: Haha, my friend smokes.
Katrina: 别人教你的嘛
Katrina: Someone taught you?
Katrina: 好好
Katrina: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 大家到后来都变成烟酒都占的人了
Katrina: Everyone eventually ends up smoking and drinking.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 呃把花拿走是吧
Katrina: Uh, should I take the flowers away?
Katrina: 清一下桌子
Katrina: Clean the table.
Katrina: 噔噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Dun dun dun dun dun.
Katrina: 哼哼
Katrina: Hmph.
Katrina: 23号约了晚饭
Katrina: Dinner is set for the 23rd.
Shure: 这今天怪不得心情这么好
Shure: No wonder you're in such a good mood today.
Katrina: 居然不喜欢吃小龙虾
Katrina: You actually don't like eating crayfish?
Katrina: 这让我很生气
Katrina: That makes me really mad.
Shure: 要是喜欢吃小龙虾可以去那个湖大
Shure: If you like eating crayfish, you can go to that lake.
Katrina: 吃不到一块去生气了
Katrina: Can't eat together, so got angry.
Katrina: 还他妈没开始呢
Katrina: Haven't even started yet.
Katrina: 太没品了这人
Katrina: This person is so tasteless.
Shure: 谈不了一点
Shure: Can't really talk about it.
Katrina: 还不吃牛蛙真的是
Shure: 那你们想吃什么
Shure: So what do you guys want to eat?
Katrina: 非要吃潮汕牛肉
Katrina: Insist on eating Chaoshan beef.
Shure: 哈哈好
Shure: Haha, alright.
Shure: 北邮旁边那个叫什么巴河里
Shure: 还有哪一个来着
Shure: And what's the other one?
Shure: 都特别好吃
Shure: They're all super delicious.
Katrina: 之前他带我吃过金谷园
Katrina: He took me to eat at Jinguyuan before.
Shure: 这是我们北邮特色
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 还带我吃了一个你们旁边的一家涮肉
Katrina: He also took me to a hotpot place near you guys.
Katrina: 就是海淀对面
Katrina: Right across from Haidian.
Shure: 那个锡纸板那个吗
Shure: Is it that tin foil one?
Katrina: 西什么我不知道
Katrina: West what? I don't know.
Shure: 西直门
Shure: Xizhimen.
Katrina: 反正就你们学校走出来一会就到了
Katrina: Anyway, you walk out from your school and you'll get there soon.
Shure: 那我不知道那个
Shure: I don't know that place.
Katrina: 是海淀小区
Katrina: It's Haidian Community.
Shure: 我每次都去那个
Shure: I always go to that...
Shure: 西直门那个
Shure: ...Xizhimen place.
Shure: 洋访胜利
Shure: Yangfang Victory.
Katrina: 没有心情很好啊
Katrina: No, I'm in a really good mood.
Katrina: 我吗
Katrina: Me?
Katrina: 只是因为我今天睡饱了
Katrina: It's just because I slept well today.
Katrina: 我今天没定闹钟
Katrina: I didn't set an alarm today.
Katrina: 因为我看昨天晚上没有说今天几点
Katrina: Because I saw there was no specific time mentioned last night.
Shure: 嘴角比AK还难压
Shure: It's harder to control the corners of my mouth than an AK.
Katrina: 不是喊出
Katrina: It's not shouting out.
Katrina: 喊出来吃饭还是很简单的
Katrina: Shouting out to eat is still easy.
Katrina: 只是说还是很怪
Katrina: It's just that it still feels weird.
Shure: 问其他的一律不答
Shure: Ask others, they don't respond.
Shure: 吃饭吗吃哈哈哈
Shure: Eat? Yeah, eat. Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈对
Katrina: Hahaha, right.
Katrina: 你总觉得好到位
Katrina: You always feel it's just right.
Jake:来负责一下
Jake: Come on, take responsibility.
Katrina: 点的什么呀这个
Katrina: What did you order?
Jake:这个他路上撒了卤煮
Jake: He spilled the sauce on the way here.
Jake:撒的很
Jake: Spilled a lot.
Jake:可以撒的很卤煮越来越看越想吃了
Jake: But it looks so good, I just want to eat it more.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 所以它是一种冒菜吗
Lucia: So, is it a kind of spicy hot pot?
Shure: no no no这卤煮闻着下水味就有点重
Shure: No no no, this stew has a really strong offal smell.
Jake:下水味重是吧
Jake: The offal smell is strong, right?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Lucia: 什么它里面是下水吗
Lucia: Wait, is there offal in it?
Lucia: 不是它是用下水做的吗
Lucia: Or is it made with offal?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:就是硬煮
Jake: It's just hard boiled.
Lucia: 硬煮
Lucia: Hard boiled.
Jake:就是煮啊煮煮煮直接煮
Jake: Yeah, just boil, boil, boil.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Shure: 这其实
Shure: Actually,
Shure: 分两个人分吃吧
Shure: Let's split it between two people.
Shure: 或者三个人
Shure: Or three people.
Shure: 或者自己每个人拿个小碗接着吃吧
Shure: Or everyone can take a small bowl and continue eating.
Jake:拿着小碗接着吃
Jake: Take a small bowl and continue eating.
Shure: 拿小碗接着吃
Shure: Take a small bowl and continue eating.
Shure: 对行
Shure: Yeah, sure.
Jake:你多整点小碗我找不着碗
Jake: Get more small bowls, I can't find any.
Shure: 多整点小碗
Shure: Get more small bowls.
Shure: 行那去楼下吃楼上吃
Shure: Okay, should we eat downstairs or upstairs?
Lucia: 我看一下楼下的桌子现在情况怎么样
Lucia: Let me check the situation with the tables downstairs.
Lucia: 应该大家都把
Lucia: Should be everyone moved
Jake:很不怎么样哈哈哈哈哦这样
Jake: Not looking great, haha, oh, like this.
Lucia: 呃不是大家都把花搬走了吗
Lucia: Didn't everyone move the flowers away?
Shure: 咱在楼上吃吧
Shure: Let's eat upstairs.
Shure: 然后把那个电脑收一下
Shure: And tidy up the computer.
Shure: 我的室友们给点力呀
Shure: My roommates, lend a hand!
Shure: 不是我在呼唤我
Shure: No, I'm calling my...
Shure: 我真实的室友
Shure: My actual roommates.
Katrina: 嗯什么东西
Katrina: Hmm, what?
Katrina: 这是北京特产吗
Katrina: Is this a Beijing specialty?
Shure: 这是北京嘎嘎特产
Shure: This is a genuine Beijing specialty
Shure: 第一次吃的时候我根本接受不了
Shure: The first time I tried it, I couldn't stand it
Shure: 但是越吃越香
Shure: But the more you eat, the better it tastes
Shure: 但是这家闻着不正宗我跟你讲
Shure: But this one doesn't smell authentic, I'm telling you
Katrina: 我说你怎么一股大肠味
Katrina: I was wondering why you smelled like intestines
Shure: 对啊他就是啊
Shure: Yeah, he does
Katrina: 我不吃大肠
Katrina: I don't eat intestines
Shure: 你不吃大肠
Shure: You're not eating intestines?
Shure: 他还有那什么
Shure: He still has that...
Shure: 他还有
Shure: He still has...
Shure: 其他的还点了驴肉火烧
Shure: They also ordered donkey meat buns.
Katrina: 饼啊
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 饼吗
Shure: 就是类似于一种肉夹馍吧
Shure: It's like a kind of meat sandwich, right?
Katrina: 哎我靠
Shure: 早餐不不喝
Shure: 公主心意了是吗
Katrina: 这是早餐
Shure: 对啊差不多
Katrina: 不是我觉得好尴尬
Katrina: 我不想去那个说了好奇怪
Shure:  （歌声） 那里春风沉醉
Shure: (singing) Where the spring breeze lingers.
Shure: （歌声）那里绿草如茵
Shure: (singing) Where the green grass is lush.
Shure: （歌声）多少年以后
Shure: (singing) How many years later.
Shure: （歌声）浮云般游走
Shure: (singing) Drifting like floating clouds.
Shure: 刷点碗吧出来
Shure: Wash some bowls, come out.
Shure: 这个屋子味都杂了你知道吗
Shure: The smell in this room is all mixed up, you know?
Shure: 往右扭头是咖啡味
Shure: Turn right, it smells like coffee.
Shure: 往左扭头是大肠哈哈哈
Shure: Turn left, it smells like intestines, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina: 把我房间关起来
Katrina: Close my room.
Alice:现成的可以喝一下了吗
Alice: Can we drink the ready one?
Shure: 什么咖啡吗
Shure: What, coffee?
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh my.